Today we're going to talk about
something called revenue equivalence.
So so far we've studied a few different
auction formats and we've solved for the
equilibrium of these auction formats and
we found this kind of surprising or
peculiar finding that the amount of
revenue that these auctions generate
doesn't seem to depend on which auction
format we use. So I want to first review
a few of those examples and then today
we're going to try to understand in
general why this happens and what are
the limitations
and scope of this result.
So remember we first looked at the
really simple case
where we had only two bidders and each
bidder's valuation was uniformly and
independently drawn from the 01
interval, right? So in the simple case
we had V1 and V2. This is bidder one's
valuation. This is bidder two's
valuation. They were in 01 and they were
uniform AND INDEPENDENT.
AND IN THIS [clears throat] REALLY
SIMPLE CASE we looked at the first price
auction and we said that in the first
price auction there was an equilibrium.
Maybe I'll write B
first price auction
where
bidder i's bid if their valuation was Vi
was half of their true valuation, right?
We know in the first price auction
people bid in equilibrium less than
their true valuation. This is sometimes
called bid shading. You shade your bid
below your valuation and we saw that
this was exactly Vi over two.
And then we also found an equilibrium of
the second price auction so I'll write
SPA.
And in the second price auction, we
observed that uh the amount you pay for
the item, if you win, doesn't depend on
your bid. It only depends on other
people's bids, and we gave this argument
as to why you should always bid
truthfully in a second price auction. So
here we had bi of vi uh equals vi.
Uh but
what we noticed is well, let's try to
compute in each case how much you are
expected to pay in each of these
auctions.
Well, in a first price auction, let's
say your true valuation is vi, and this
is how much you bid.
Well,
YOUR EXPECTED PAYMENT
IS GOING TO BE
your bid times the probability that you
actually win the good. Because you only
pay your bid when you win, right? So
your expected payment is vi over two.
That's your bid, and in a first price
auction, you pay your bid if you win. So
it's the amount you pay times the
probability that you win, right? What is
the probability that you win in this
auction if your valuation is vi?
So maybe I'll say
this is going to be
probability of winning.
Well, this was a symmetric equilibrium,
right? So uh the bidder who wins is the
bidder who has the highest valuation,
right? So I'm going to win. Yeah.
>> Do you want to write it?
>> Exactly. And I guess here we have vi, so
it's going to be vi, but exactly, yeah.
Uh yeah, it could be a one.
Exactly right, right? Why is it vi?
Well, I'm going to win if my value is
higher than everyone else's, right?
Because we're all using the same
increasing bidding function.
What's the probability that my value is
higher than everyone else's? Well,
there's only two of us, so it's the
probability that the other bidder has a
value below mine. But for a uniform
distribution, if my value is VI, the
probability that the other bidder's
value is below VI is just VI, right?
This is just
you know, for uniform 0 1, if here's my
bid, here's my value VI,
I'm going to win if the other bidder's
value lies in this interval, and the
length of this interval is exactly VI.
So, we multiply by the probability of
winning, and we get VI squared over two.
This is the amount that I expect to pay
if my valuation is
And then we can do a similar calculation
here.
Uh
What is my expected payment in this
case?
Well, we're still going to multiply by
VI,
the probability of winning,
but now we can't just multiply my
probability of winning times the amount
I pay if I win, because the amount that
I pay if I win depends on what other
people bid.
So, what we have to multiply it by is
not what I pay if I win, but my expected
payment
conditional on winning.
And this is a general way of breaking
down how much I expect to pay, right? I
only pay if I win, so the expected
amount that I pay is my probability of
winning times my expected payment if I
win, my expected payment conditional on
winning, right? Now, if I win, how much
do I pay? Well, I pay the second highest
bid.
If I win,
the second highest bid is the bid of the
other person,
and I know the other person is bidding
truthfully, right? So, the amount that
I'm going to pay is my opponent's
valuation.
And
it turns out what this is going to be is
Well, let's see. It's the expectation of
maybe VJ
conditional on VJ being less than or
equal to VI.
So, I'm bidder I,
I know that my valuation is VI. When do
I win? I win exactly if my opponent's
value VJ is less than mine.
And if I do win, I pay exactly their
valuation because I pay their bid and
their bid equals their valuation.
So, it's
We're going to get this formula here.
Maybe I'll erase this arrow just to give
myself some more space. So, this is my
probability of winning.
This is my expected payment conditional
on winning. And
can we compute this conditional
expectation here? Yes.
>> Yes, we can compute it. And actually, we
can also think about how VJ is uniformly
distributed from zero to VI. So, the
expectation will just be half of VI.
>> Exactly. Let's be careful. So, VJ is
uniformly distributed from zero to one.
I mean, you're right, but you're saying
conditional on VJ being less than or
equal to VI, it's uniformly distributed
on zero to VI, right? And therefore, uh
you know, here's the example. If I know
that the other player's valuation is
below mine, well, I know it's somewhere
in here. And if it's uniform, well, it
turns out conditionally, it's still
uniform over here. What's its mean?
Well, it's just going to be the middle
of this interval, which is exactly VI
over two, right? So,
exactly here,
VI over two. So, if I compute this out,
what do I get? I also get VI over two
times VI. And what do I get? VI squared
over two.
So, here, this is just kind of a a recap
of this finding we had before that in
both the first price and the second
price auction, at least in the
equilibria that we looked at, the
expected payment made by bidder I when
her valuation is VI is exactly the same
in the two auctions, right?
And that seemed kind of puzzling. And
you know, you wonder if that's a
coincidence. Well, let's go more
generally. Let's look at the at the
general case.
So,
in the general case,
>> The general case we had N bidders
instead of just two and we didn't assume
that they were uniformly distributed. We
allowed more general distributions. So
here we had the valuations were V1 up to
VN.
And let's I think what we said is they
lived in some set V lower bar to V upper
bar
where
everything is non-negative.
So everyone's value lies somewhere
between this lower bound V lower bar and
this upper bound V upper bar. Up here
those bounds were just zero and one, but
here we're going to be more general.
And we're going to assume that these
valuations are
independent.
That is the
distribution of V2 or V3 is
statistically independent of the
distribution of V1. But now they're
drawn from a different distribution
instead of the uniform we said they have
density
F
>> [snorts]
>> over this interval
V lower bar to V upper bar.
And then we introduced one more piece of
notation. It was nice to have notation
for the distribution of the maximum of
everyone else's valuation. So we had we
looked at the max
over let's say J not equal to I
of VJ.
So I'm holding out one bidder and taking
the perspective of bidder I and I'm
thinking of all the bidders other than
bidder I. I'm looking at all of their
valuations and I'm taking the maximum.
This is another random variable, right?
As bidder I I don't know what this is. I
can form beliefs about this.
And what we said is we just had
notation. We said this has cumulative
distribution function big G and density
little g. And we had formulas for what
these are, but they don't the exact
formulas don't matter. It's just that we
can compute the distribution of this and
we gave a name to it. The cumulative
distribution is big G and the density is
uh is little G.
Notice here that uh everything here is
symmetric. So, the value of I here
doesn't matter. If I'm bidder one and
I'm thinking about what's the highest
value of everyone other than me or if
I'm bidder two and I'm saying what's the
highest value of everyone other than me,
that distribution is going to take uh is
going to be the same. Maybe just make
sure we're on the same page. If
n equals two,
what is the density G going to be?
If n equals two,
so there's two bidders.
Yeah?
Just F, right? Cuz if there's two
bidders, well,
what is the maximum of every other
bidder except me? Well, it's just the
other person.
So, this is just VJ.
And we already assumed that the
distribution of each bidder uh bidder's
valuation follows density F.
So, in this case G is just going to
reduce to F because there's only one
other uh
one other bidder. But when n is bigger
than two, then this is going to be a
more complicated form, right? But the
simple thing is the highest bidder among
my opponents, if I only have one
opponent, is just the value of my
opponent.
Okay.
Great. So, here was the general case and
we also looked at the first price
auction and the second price auction in
this case and we computed equilibria and
maybe I'll start here with the second
price auction cuz that was maybe uh
that's a bit easier to write down.
So, BI VI in the second price auction,
do people remember uh what our
equilibrium was here?
I think people know. They just don't
want to say.
If we have a second price auction, how
much should you bid if your valuation is
VI?
Yeah.
>> VI.
>> Just VI. You should just bid your
valuation. So, it turned out this we
gave this argument that in a second
price auction you always want to bid
truthfully. You always want to bid your
valuation exactly and that didn't depend
on the details of whether there's two
bidders or n bidders or what the
distributions are. That's a very robust
result. So we got
vi.
And
we can again try to compute what is your
expected
payment. Okay, this is a little tricky
here, but let's see if we can do it.
FIRST LET'S JUST WRITE IT ABSTRACTLY.
WHAT is my expected payment? Well,
it's we first have to say well there's
some chance I don't pay anything at all.
If I lose the auction, I pay nothing.
So my expected payment, it's always
helpful to break it down into the
probability that I win the auction
times the expected amount that I pay
given that I win, right? So we'll break
it down just like we did before. So let
me first write down the probability that
I win. So this is
the probability that I win
is the probability well, in this
equilibrium everyone's bidding their
valuation.
So I'm going to win if my bid is
highest, which is exactly the case if my
value is higher than everyone else's. So
I'm going to win if the probability of
the max
of j not equal to i of vj
is less than or equal to vi. And as
usual we don't have to be too careful is
it less than or equal? Is it strictly
less than? The probability is going to
be the same so we don't really have to
you know, it it doesn't really matter
what we write here. Okay. So this is the
probability that I win.
Now, what is the expected payment
conditional on winning? So
it's going to be kind of an analog of
this formula here.
Um the expected payment conditional on
winning, well it's going to be
an expectation
uh
a little more space here. Let's see how
small I can write.
Well, it's expectation conditioned on me
winning. So, I'm exactly going to win
if the max
over J not equal to I VJ is less than or
equal to VI.
Right? This is exactly the event that I
win. I'm going to win if everyone else's
valuation is below mine. Another way of
saying that is the maximum over everyone
else's valuation is weakly smaller than
mine.
And when that happens,
how much am I going to pay in the second
price auction?
Yeah.
>> VJ
>> Uh
>> VJ is like the second highest.
>> Right. And we have some notation for
that right here, right?
It's exactly So, you're exactly right.
I'm going to pay the second highest
valuation. But, what that is is it's
precisely the highest among everyone
other than me because I'm the highest.
So, you're exactly right. It is Let's
write it as this. max VJ not equal to I
of VJ. Right? So, it's crucial here,
yes, that this is the second highest
value, but in the event that I have the
highest value, well, what's the second
highest value? It's just the highest
among everyone else. So, we exactly get
uh this formula here.
And
this gets maybe
a little messy,
but we're actually able to
compute it. Let's see. So, it's going to
be an integral
from V lower bar to VI.
>> [snorts]
>> So, technically we get into some
conditional densities. It gets a little
messy, but let me just write out what we
get. We're going to get T
or maybe I'll write X
G of X
for G of VI DX.
So,
I just wrote this probability as G of VI
because big G is the cumulative
distribution function associated with
this random variable. So, the
probability that this random variable is
below VI is by definition G of VI. So,
here I'm just using a definition.
For this part, it's a little trickier.
I'm using what's called a conditional
density. I'm saying what is the
conditional density of the highest value
of my opponents given that their
valuation is below VI. And this here is
my conditional density.
I'm integrating this between V lower bar
and VI because I'm focusing on the event
that the highest value of my opponents
is lower than mine.
And you know, maybe we don't need to get
too caught up in in the algebra here,
but we can just see that this G of VI
and this G of VI cancel, and we're going
to get a really simple formula.
So, this is my general formula
for
how much I expect to pay in the second
price auction if my valuation is VI.
Let's do one more. Let's kind of finish
things off here.
So,
and as I said, if if this conditional
density is new to you, we it won't come
up again. So, the the kind of the final
answer is maybe what's important here.
Let's just do one more, the
B I first price auction
of VI.
We actually computed this. Didn't we
remember
uh what this what this was? We computed
this in class before. Maybe I'll just
write it down. It turns out we had a
formula that
actually looked exactly like this. This
was actually our formula. So, it turns
out we derived this in class I think
last Thursday. We used a differential
equation, and we found that
it's exactly this.
So, this is just uh
the formula that we had.
But now, if this is how much I'm bidding
in a first-price auction, what is the
expected payment that I'm going to make?
Well, in the first-price auction, what I
pay is my bid.
So, my expected payment is just my bid,
how much I pay, times the probability
that I actually have to pay my bid.
But when do I pay my bid? I pay my bid
when I win.
Right? So, my expected payment
well, it's just
b i f p a
of v i, my bid, times the probability
that I win. What is the probability that
I win?
Well, it's the probability that my value
is higher than everyone else. It's
exactly this thing we already computed
down here, and we have a simple formula
for it. It's just g of v i.
And this is
probability of winning.
Okay. Well, we already have a formula
for b i f p a of v i, so let's plug in
this here,
and we see that the g of v i cancels,
and we get
the same integral.
And we get this.
So, this seems like it probably is not a
coincidence, right?
That we've gotten exactly the same
answer in both cases. Yes?
>> So, why is b i of v i this integral when
we had already said it was just v i?
>> Uh
the key is the superscript here.
s p a. So, in a second-price auction,
the equilibrium bidding strategy is for
me to bid exactly my valuation. Okay?
So, everything we did here was for the
second price auction. Now, we're
changing cases here, and I should have
been more clear about this. Now, we're
moving to the first price auction.
In the first price auction, the
equilibrium is different. In the first
price auction, I don't want to bid my
true valuation. If I bid my true
valuation in a first price auction, then
I can never come out ahead.
Cuz either I don't win, or I win, but
then I have to pay my my bid. So,
deriving this was a lot harder. We spent
basically all of class deriving a
differential equation, and in the end we
got this formula. So,
uh if you don't, you know, this is kind
of hard to see. This took us like an
hour to get to, but it should be in your
notes from from last class. Yeah, so the
answer why are these different? These
are different equilibria of different
auctions.
Uh but, the surprising thing is we get
exactly the same formula for the
expected uh payment in both cases.
Uh and let's just see if that's
consistent. I mean, up here
I got vi squared over two.
Is this formula going to give me vi
squared over two in the really simple
example in the simple uniform example?
Can we see this little calculus
exercise?
Well, in the uniform example, what is g?
In our example where we had two bidders
and the values were uniformly
distributed over 0 1?
It's just one, right? Because the first
observation that you made was that g
equals f when we have two bidders,
right?
But, if
our valuations are uniformly
distributed, what is f? It's just one,
right? So, if we just plug in one here,
we get the integral from v lower bar to
vi.
Uh well,
so, let me go through our example. So,
in our simple example,
everything works out
because g of x equals one.
And what is v lower bar?
Zero, right? And v upper bar is one, but
that doesn't show up. So, now we just
get the integral
from zero to VI
of X DX.
And this is something people should
know, right? This is just the
antiderivative. This is just X squared
over two. So, we just get VI squared
over two.
And this just confirms the two formulas
that we got up here.
So, everything's consistent. That's
good. And we have this kind of
surprising finding. So,
note
the equilibrium
expected payment
is the same in the first price auction
and the second price auction.
Be a little more precise. I'm talking
about a particular equilibrium that we
computed, but I'll be a little looser.
The equilibrium expected payment is the
same
in the first price auction
and the second price auction.
And notice how this happened, came
about, getting back to the question, the
rules of these auctions are different.
So, if the players bid the same way in
these two auctions, their payments would
definitely be different. But, the
equilibrium bidding behavior is also
different. So, the rules of the auction
are different, the bidding behavior is
different, and somehow these things
offset in exactly the right way that we
get exactly the same formula in both
cases.
And I think it feels, to me at least,
that this can't be a coincidence. It
seems like there's something else going
on here. And what's going on is exactly
what's called revenue equivalence. And
today we're going to try to understand
more generally why and under what
conditions this is true. So, I I think
this should be kind of a puzzle. It's
not at all clear why we get the same
answer here. And today we want to kind
of get to the bottom and understand this
puzzle. Um but, this was to be
motivation for what we do. So, if this
is unclear, what we do won't be
motivated. So, let me pause for some
questions here. Everything clear so far?
Okay.
Well,
so far we said that the equilibrium
expected payment was the same in these
two auctions.
What if we use a different auction
format? Maybe we could use a third price
auction or fourth price auction, all pay
auction. There's many different auction
formats we could use.
And we'd like our theorem to speak to
any auction format you can come up with.
So, to do that we have to think, well,
what is an auction? Like, how can I
define a general abstract auction? So,
let's be really general. What is Maybe
I'll call this a generalized auction.
And I'm still going to be in this
setting over here. So, I'm still
assuming
uh the these assumptions about the
environment, these assumptions about how
much each person values the item, but
what's going to be general is the
auction format that we use.
Well, at bottom, what is an auction?
Well, first I have to specify what bids
are allowed, right? So far we've allowed
bids to be real numbers, but you could
have really weird auctions where bids
can only be multiples of five, or maybe
you can only say yes or no, or
uh maybe you say I really like it or I
don't really like it. There's a lot of
different ways we could do it. So, a
generalized auction format, first we
have to specify THE BID SETS.
B1,
>> [applause]
>> B2,
all the way up to BN.
So, this is specifying what each bidder
is allowed to bid. You could think of
these as
messages, or, you know, there's a lot of
different ways we can think about it,
but this is just the set of choices that
each bidder has in the auction. Okay?
And then we need to specify
an allocation rule.
An allocation rule says, well, if we
collect some bid by bidder one and some
bid by bidder two and all the way up to
a bid by bidder n, what do we do?
Well, the auctioneer has to specify two
things.
The allocation rule is who gets the
good.
And then the payment rule is how much
does everyone pay? So, we'll call it the
allocation rule and maybe the payment or
transfer rule.
Now, for instance, so far we've only
looked at auctions where all the
auctions we've looked at
you only pay if you win.
But, that's actually not a requirement
of an auction. In fact, there's
something called an all-pay auction
where everyone submits their bid and you
have to pay your bid whether or not you
win the item or not.
That may sound like a
appealing auction, but of course you're
going to bid less in in response to
that, right? So, we're actually going to
allow pretty general payment rules and
transfer rules. We've generally looked
at allocation rules where the highest
bidder gets the item, but we could be
even more general. Maybe we like one of
the bidders more and we want to always
give them the item.
So, in general, what is an allocation
rule? It's going to be a function, maybe
I'll call it Q,
from
B1
cross Bn
to
well,
it's going to take in a profile of bids
by all the players.
And what it's going to spit out is it
should spit out something like, I give
the good to player one
or I give the good to player two or I
give the good to player n.
The problem is sometimes we have to
randomize because sometimes two bidders
will bid the same amount.
And then we might have to flip a coin to
see who gets the item. So, we have to
allow these kinds of lotteries. So, I'm
going to write it's going to map to what
I'll call delta,
where delta is just going to be the set
of lotteries. It's going to be the set
of all vectors
Q1 up to Qn
where the interpretation is if these are
the submitted bids, then Q1 is going to
tell us the probability that player one
gets the item.
So, these are going to be
So, Q1 through QN is greater than equal
to zero.
Now, I want to emphasize I want to
emphasize this here.
I don't require equality.
So, what's the interpretation here? What
if I were to say, "Okay, if these are
the bids that are submitted,
I'm going to allocate the good with
these probabilities that sum to strictly
less than one."
Could this ever happen? What's the
interpretation? Yeah?
>> Well, there's also the situation which I
can't say.
>> Right, exactly. So, why do I have to
allocate the good?
I might say, and we see this in
auctions, no one's bid was high enough.
I'm not happy with the bids people
submitted, I'm going to keep the keep
the good myself. And that would
correspond to
uh all of these being zero, actually,
right? So, we allow
the auctioneer to keep the good.
So, more formally,
one minus the sum of the QIs is exactly
the probability that the auctioneer
keeps the good. So, one way of thinking
about this is it's a probability
distribution, not over bidders one
through N, but over the auctioneer and
bidders one through N, and it doesn't
have to sum up to one because the
auctioneer could get the good with some
probability.
Okay?
So, this is just a definition of this
set delta that I'm going to use. So,
delta is the set of sometimes it's
called sub-probabilities. It's like
distributions over who gets the good,
but they might sum to less than one.
Okay?
Now, what about a payment or transfer
rule?
Uh that's going to be a function T
to RN.
Where
as a function of the bids, I'm going to
specify T1, how much player one has to
pay me, T2, how much player two has to
pay me, and and so on.
So, just to uh make sure we we
understand what's going on,
let's look at a really simple example.
Let's look at the first price auction.
Okay? So, in the standard first price
auction, what were these bid sets, B1
through BN?
What did we allow people to to bid?
Yeah.
>> Any real number that's positive.
>> Any real number that's positive, or
maybe non-negative, yeah. So, I think,
you know, it doesn't really the details
don't matter too much if it if we allow
negative bids, but you're right. So far,
we haven't allowed negative bids. So, in
that case, we had B1
is equal to BN
is equal to maybe I'll write R plus, or
maybe I'll be a bit more explicit. I'll
write zero
to infinity, right?
So, what we said is, what is the bid set
for each player? The bid set is just the
set of all non-negative real numbers.
That's what we allowed you to bid.
Maybe in reality, maybe you can only bid
multiples of a cent or something, and we
could add more complexity, but but we'll
just allow this for now,
Now, specifying the allocation rule and
transfer rule,
it's just a bit messy to write it all
out because they're whole functions. So,
let's just go through an example, one
example. What if um
say
n equals two. So, we have two bidders.
>> [snorts]
>> Let's see if we can compute
Q of
3 4
and T of 3 4.
So, it's really just to make sure we
understand the notation that's going on.
Right?
So, if n equals two,
the bid set for player one is just a
non-negative real number.
The bid set for player two is just the
set of non-negative real numbers.
So, the domain of the allocation rule
and the transfer rule, they have to say,
if bidder one bids this number
and bidder two bids this number, who do
we allocate the good to and how much do
we make them pay?
So, when I write Q of 3 4,
the interpretation of this is
three is the bid by bidder one,
four is the bid by bidder two,
and we need to say what happens if
bidder one bids three and bidder two
bids four. And this is really just to
check our notation here. So, what is Q
of 3 4?
Yeah.
>> Wouldn't it be a 0 1?
>> 0 1, right? Because here,
because bidder two's bid is higher than
bidder one's bid, we need to allocate
the good to bidder two, and we have
notation for that. Our notation just
tells us the probability that each
bidder gets the good. Now, probability
seem a bit weird here. They're just 0 or
1, right? We always give the good to
bidder two if bidder two's bid is
higher. So, this is just going to be the
vector 0  1. That says
we give the good to bidder one with
probability zero and we give the good to
bidder two with probability one.
Uh what about the
vector T? T of 3 4? What is that going
to be? Yeah.
>> 0 4.
>> 0 4, right?
This says, well,
this first component we might call T1 of
3 4. This is how much bidder one has to
pay. Well, bidder one got outbid.
They're not getting the item and
therefore they don't pay.
So, they pay zero.
Bidder two
was the highest bidder. They're winning
the item and in the rules of the first
price auction, they pay their bid, so we
get 0 4,
Now, what if I were to change this to a
second price auction? If I change this
to a second price auction, what would
change here? Would Q change? Would T
change? What would be different?
Uh yeah.
>> Q would not change because still the
person bidding four
bidding Well, they got the bid four in
this case for bid. T would change,
however, because they would only have to
pay three.
>> Exactly. So, notice when you compare the
first and second price auction, they
actually use the same allocation rule.
And a lot of auctions use this
allocation rule. The allocation rule is
pretty simple. We allocate it to the
highest bidder.
They both use the allocation rule. The
difference between the first price
auction and the second price auction is
the payment rule. How much people have
to pay? And indeed, down here what we
would get is 0 3.
If it were second price auction, the
first bidder got outbid, they still lose
the item and pay nothing.
The second bidder in a second price
auction though pays the Well, bidder two
is the highest bidder, they pay the
second highest bid. Well, what's the
second highest bid between three and
four? It would just be three. So, we'd
have to change this four to a three if
we wanted to do uh the first price
auction. What about an all pay auction?
What would this be if it were an all pay
auction?
Well, then it would just be 3 4. Right?
Because bidder one would have to pay
three even though they didn't win the
good, and bidder two would would pay
four, they pay their own
uh Okay. So, I think we understand the
notation here.
And now that we have this generalized
auction format, we want to try to
understand these uh expected payments.
Now, to talk about how much people
expect to pay, we have to first have an
equilibrium in mind, right? Let's This
is sort of a key conceptual point that
when I say Notice when I said expected
payments, I said equilibrium expected
payments because just from the auction
format alone, we have no idea how much
people are going to pay until we specify
how people actually bid, right? So,
first we need to choose or focus our
attention on an equilibrium of the
auction, and then given that
equilibrium, we can compute how much
people are expected to pay.
So, consider We're going to consider
an equilibrium
a Bayes-Nash equilibrium
of some generalized auction.
And let's just make sure we understand
what kind of object this is.
So, a base Nash equilibrium is going to
specify functions. Let's see.
B1, usually we use star, but I think I'm
actually going to use hats today cuz
we're going to have to take some
derivatives and with the stars it's a
bit messy. So, bidder one's equilibrium
strategy is going to be a mapping from
>> [applause]
>> V lower bar to V upper bar
to B1.
All the way down to BN HAT.
SO, REMEMBER A BASE NASH EQUILIBRIUM IS
A strategy profile
and a strategy profile just specifies a
strategy or bidding function for each of
the players.
Notice here that in general these bid
sets could be different and our our
strategies have to reflect that. So,
what is bidder one do?
They know what their true value is. It's
somewhere between V lower bar and V
upper bar.
And to each true value their bidding
function specifies how much they bid.
Well, what is a bid? A bid is just
something in the set B1. Remember this
is really abstract. B1 could be I like
it or I don't like it.
And then my strategy would say for which
values do I tell the auctioneer I like
it and for which values do I tell the
auctioneer I don't like it.
Um, and then all the way down to bidder
N whose bidding function takes each
value they could possibly have and
assigns it to some bid that's feasible,
some bid that's in the bid set that the
auctioneer has presented.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay.
So,
we're considering a base Nash
equilibrium
and what we're interested in is the
payments, right? We're interested in the
expected payment that each bidder makes.
And we might also be interested in how
likely each bidder is to to win the
good. So, given this we want to define
what we might call the equilibrium
expected
allocation and payments.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, let's first define
the
allocation. Maybe I'll call it
Q
I hat. Let's focus on bidder one. I
think it just makes the notation a
little easier. Q1 hat
of V1.
So, the hat reminds us that this depends
on the equilibrium, B1 hat. And what I
want to compute here is, let's say we're
playing this generalized auction,
and we're following this Bayes-Nash
equilibrium.
Suppose I'm bidder one.
Suppose my true valuation for the good
is V1.
What is my
probability, or my expected probability
of winning the item?
Well,
whether I win the item depends on what
other people's valuations are. So, I
need to take an expectation.
So, I'm going to take the an expectation
of
Let's write this.
Let's make sure we understand what's
going on here.
And I'll say this expectation is over
V2
through VN.
>> [clears throat]
>> Why do I not take expectations over V1?
Well, I know V1. I'm bidder one. I know
what V1 is. So, this is what's I think
really tricky about this notation. When
you see V1 in here, that's just a
number.
That's something I know.
When you see VN, that's something I
don't know, and that's something that's
random.
So, think of V1, it's just something
like two. It's It's a number, we're not
taking an expectation over it, but
everyone else's bid everyone else's
value we are taking an expectation over
it because we don't know what it is.
So, what this is saying is
if
my value is V1 as bidder one, well then
the amount I'm going to bid in
equilibrium is B1 hat of V1, right?
That's what my equilibrium bidding
strategy tells me I should bid.
Now let's take the example of bidder N,
well I don't know what bidder N's value
is.
But if their value is VN, then how much
do they bid? They bid BN hat of VN.
And we'll do the same for bidder N-1 and
bidder N-3 all the way down to bidder
two.
Right?
So, what's in here
is the profile of bids that are
submitted when we're following the
equilibrium strategy and bidder one's
value is V1, bidder two's value is V2,
all the way up to bidder N's value is
VN.
Now, bidder one knows her own value V1,
but she doesn't know these other values,
so that's why we take an expectation.
And then notice we have to feed in this
profile of bids into our allocation
function. And I realize I made a mistake
here, we need a one here.
Should be Q
one.
Because this is the profile of bids.
Q1 of this profile is going to specify
the probability that player one or
bidder one gets the item
when this is the submitted profile of
bids.
And then we compute expectations here.
But I think this is a little abstract,
so clear Yeah.
>> So, so player one can't know her own
allocation function, right? Because it
depends on like other people's values.
>> So, let's be clear. There's a key
difference here between the function and
the value of the function. So, she does
know the allocation rule. She knows if
these are the bids that are submitted,
then this is this is the amount I'm
going to get. But you're right, she
doesn't know the bids that are actually
submitted because she doesn't know how
other people bid. So, this thing in
here, she doesn't know what value this
takes. The value this takes is going to
depend on these bids here.
But, she's able to form beliefs over
that. She's able to say things like,
"Well, I don't know, let's say there's
two bidders, I don't know what bidder
two is going to bid."
But, if bidder two bids five, this is
the probability I get the good. If
bidder two bids seven, this is the
probability that I get the good. And
because she has a belief about the
distribution from which bidder two's
valuations are drawn, and she believes
that bidder two is following bidder
two's equilibrium strategy, she's able
to compute an expectation here. So, she
doesn't know the actual, I guess what's
also tricky here,
it's weird to talk about
this is kind of a probability on the
inside, and then we're also taking an
expected probability. I know that's a
little weird, but think of this number
as basically always being zero or one on
the inside. So, it's we're basically
saying, "What's the probability that I
get the good?" So, we're taking an
expectation of something that's
sometimes one, it's one if I win, and
and sometimes zero, it's zero if I lose.
These tie-breaking stuff is not really
going to going to come up.
Any other questions? Great. Good
question here. Okay.
Great. So, this is the equilibrium
probability that I get the good if I'm
bidder one,
and my valuation is V1. Now, let's do
the same with the transfer. So, we want
to define T1 hat of V1.
So, this is exactly the object that we
were computing over here. We were
saying, "If I'm bidder V1, if I'm bidder
one, and my valuation is V1, what is the
expected amount that I'm going to pay in
this particular auction, in this
particular equilibrium of the auction?"
So, again, we're going to take
expectations.
Again, our expectations are going to be
over V2 through VN, because those are
the values that bidder one does not
know.
And now, we're going to write T1
of B1 hat V1
all the way up to
VN hat VN
here. And maybe I'll
make it clear this is known
but these are uncertain.
From the perspective of bidder one.
So, we have
bidder one's bid
all the way up to bidder n's bid. That
forms the profile of bids. The
auctioneer says, "If I get this profile
of bids, this is how much I'm going to
ask player one to pay."
And then we're taking expectations over
that.
So,
we've now kind of formalized our
question. Revenue equivalence tells us
that this function T1 hat of V1 seems to
take the same form
in a lot of different auction formats
and a lot of different equilibria.
In both the equilibrium of the first
price auction and the equilibrium of the
second price auction, this function was
the same. And we'd like to understand
why that is.
So, that's at a high level uh what we
want to do.
Okay.
Well, we're going to have to use the
fact that this is a base Nash
equilibrium.
So, the fact that this is a base Nash
equilibrium
tells me that
let's say take the perspective of bidder
one
who has valuation V1.
Okay?
What we know
is that bidding
B1 hat of V1
is optimal.
>> [snorts]
>> Given the way everyone else is bidding.
Right?
I could bid whatever I want, but bidding
B1 hat of V1 is the best possible bid
for me. It maximizes my expected
utility.
And a kind of weird
way you want to think about this
is
you know
that tells me that bidding B1 hat of V1
is better than any other bid I could
make.
But these other bids, you know, as you
said we they're numbers, they could be
words, we don't really know what these
things are. But in particular what this
tells us is that
bidding
and this is sort of the key observation
bidding B1 hat of V1
is weakly better
than bidding
B1 hat of V1 prime
for all V1 prime.
So in a sense I haven't done anything
here, but this actually turns out to be
the crucial observation. So the point is
bidding B1 hat of V1 is better than any
other bid.
So in particular, what's another bid I
could make?
I could choose the bid that I'm supposed
to make in this equilibrium if my true
valuation is V1 prime. Here V1 prime is
just a different valuation. I could do
that.
But
following my equilibrium bidding
strategy must be better than this
alternative bid B1 of V prime.
And then the name of the game here is
just to try to write out mathematically
what this means
in terms of these functions here.
So it's very useful to contemplate this
particular alternative bid because we
can use this alternative bid, we can
express my utility from this alternative
bid in terms of these functions here.
And that's really the the key step. So
let's uh
we come back over here.
>> I really want to emphasize everything
we're going to do now is just following
from this simple observation. So, if
there's any questions on this, I think
this is key. Yes, thank you.
>> On to the second slide that for every
unique item in the bid set there's like
the same valuation that maps to it.
>> Uh
that's a very subtle question. It does
not imply that. So,
um
Uh so, I think you're you're basically
asking, yeah, are they are the bidding
functions like onto, right? Are they
subjective functions? Uh
if they were onto, then these function
statements would be equivalent. In
general, the bidding functions are not
onto, so it's still the case that this
implies this, but not the converse. So,
we're not using that assumption. We're
actually if that is not if that
assumption is violated, then we're
actually throwing away information
because we're saying we know that this
bid is better than every other bid, even
bids that no one ever chooses in
equilibrium. But, in particular, we know
we know this. So, we're throwing away
information uh potentially. We're not
even considering it's true that this bid
is better than a bid that's never
chosen, but we don't even need to use
that that fact. Uh but we're so we're
not requiring that.
Yes.
>> So, why can't uh B hat B1 hat of V1
prime technically just represent all
other possible bidding strategies?
>> Um you said
could you maybe rephrase I'm not sure if
I quite follow, yeah.
>> Because there's infinite other bidding
strategies.
>> You're right. So,
I think the key here is I'm just using
this forward arrow, okay? I'm not saying
that this is that if this is true and
this relates to this question, I'm not
saying if this is true, then this must
be an equilibrium. I'm only going in one
direction. I'm saying we know that this
is an equilibrium
and an implication of the fact that it's
an equilibrium, because it's an
equilibrium, I'm better off bidding B
hat of V1
than making any alternative bid.
So, in particular, one implication of
that is I don't want to bid five. I
don't want to bid three. I don't want to
bid this.
Maybe we're not considering all the
other possible bids, that's fine.
Uh we're we're maybe we're throwing away
information here, but uh it's certainly
an implication of equilibrium that this
must hold.
>> When you say throwing away information,
what information are you referring to?
>> Uh what I mean is
the definition of equilibrium tells a
lot of things, and I'm only using some
logical implications of the definition
of equilibrium.
Uh so it's like I have like 10
equations, and I'm only using nine of
them. And the 10th equation's true, but
I'm just not focusing on it. I'm not
using that fact.
Um
and
maybe this all abstract stuff makes more
sense once we go through the argument.
>> So you're basically saying like bidding
B1 hat of V1 is possible, and like
there's other strategies that we're not
comparing to. We're just comparing to
the bids B1 hat of V1 in different
markets.
>> Exactly. So the fact that bidding B1 hat
of V1 opt is optimal tells me a lot. It
tells me that bidding B1 hat of V1 is
better than any other bid I could come
up with.
But
it's certainly better than these special
bids.
And I'm only going to use that fact
here. Even though I know it's better
than some other bids, too, I'm not going
to worry. I don't even need to use that
fact. Uh yeah. Okay. So now, uh
as we said, not equivalent, but an
implication of equilibrium is this
observation, and now we just want to
write this observation down
mathematically using our notation here.
Okay? So what we want to say is what is
my expected utility if I bid this?
What is my expected utility if I bid
this? And then we want to have an
inequality between them. Okay? So let's
take the first. What is my So what is my
utility from bidding
B1 hat
of V1?
Well
it's going to be V1
times the probability that I win
minus
my expected payment.
Right? This is what my utility is. When
I enter an auction, I say, "Well, this
is my probability of winning.
Whenever I win, I get my valuation for
the good. But then I have to pay, well,
we'll just subtract my expected payment
because we're assuming here people are
risk-neutral. Right?
So, what is my probability of winning if
I bid B1 hat of V1 using our notation
over there?
>> Just a Q
hat of
>> of V1, right? So, this is Q1 hat of V1.
Okay? And then what is my expected
payment?
Right?
Now, the tricky part, what if I instead
bid
I deviate and instead of bidding what
I'm supposed to bid in equilibrium, I
make a different bid. Specifically, I
bid B1 hat
of V1 prime.
Well, the crucial point is what is my
utility? Well, first,
I still have a V1 here. Let's not get
confused. My value is still V1. The fact
that I'm bidding differently doesn't
change my value to V1 prime. My value is
still V1. So, it's going to be my value
here times again my probability of
winning minus my expected payment.
What is the probability of winning now
going to be?
>> Q1 hat of V1 prime.
>> Right. So, I just plug in, you know,
if I look carefully at this formula, if
I replace B1 hat of V1 with B1 hat of V1
prime, well, then that's just the
definition of this function evaluated at
V1 prime.
So, I'm going to get
Q1 hat
V1 prime
minus T1 hat
>> [snorts]
>> And this makes sense. What's the
definition this? This tells me if I use
bidding, if I use the bid B1 hat of V1
prime, what is my probability of
winning?
And kind of the crucial thing going on
here is that my probability of winning
only depends on how much I bid. It
doesn't depend on my true valuation. It
just depends on what I bid. So, the V1
prime here is really reflecting my bid,
not my true valuation.
Okay?
So, now what do we know?
Well, we know this is greater than or
equal to this. And maybe I've
interpreted things so much, it's nicer
to to kind of start a clean board and
just write down our inequality.
So, what do we know?
So, what we know
is that
for all
V1, V1 prime,
remember the interpretation here is V1
is my true value, V1 prime is sort of
the value that I pretend to have when I
bid.
Well, we must have
V1
Q1 hat of V1
minus Q1 hat of V1
greater than or equal to
So, I've just brought that equation down
here.
And maybe it's easier if we say for all
V1, this holds
for all V1 prime. Just a slightly
different perspective.
>> [snorts]
>> Well,
what does this tell me?
Well,
I have some function on the right side
that depends on V1 prime.
But it's always smaller than this
left-hand side.
So,
in particular, what that tells me
is that the value of V1 prime
that maximizes this right-hand side must
be V1 itself.
So, that tells me that V1, let's use our
argmax notation, is an element of the
argmax
over V1 prime
of V1.
In words, what is this saying? It's
saying, if my true value is V1,
I could bid as if my valuation is V1
prime for any other value V1 prime,
but because we know that I'm playing an
equilibrium,
the best thing for me to do is to bid as
if I am myself, to bid as if my value V1
prime is exactly V1. And that's what uh
this is telling us
All right?
And now, let's just compute the
first-order condition.
So, if V1 is a maximizer of this,
then we should be able to take the
derivative of this with respect to V1
prime
and then plug in V1 prime equals V1, and
we should get zero. So, let's let's do
that.
So, it's going to be a little tricky
with the primes. You have to interpret
the primes carefully. So, this is V1 Q1
hat prime
V1 prime minus T1 hat prime V1 prime
evaluated at V1 prime equals V1, this
should be zero.
Sorry, the primes This prime on the
inside is just a symbol, and this prime
on the outside is a derivative. I Sorry,
that can be a bit confusing here.
So, you could call V1 prime Z if you
wanted it wouldn't make a difference.
Uh and what do we get?
We get V1
Q1 prime V1
Minus, sorry.
Uh so this equals zero or I could say it
implies that they're equal.
Wow, so a lot of work.
But now we've narrowed things down a
lot. I have a formula for the derivative
of this expected payment that I make
in terms of my probability of getting
the good. Okay?
So now
the trick is we're just going to
integrate this.
So if
if this equals zero
that tells me that this derivative
equals this.
Right? So now we can just integrate this
from V lower bar and see what happens.
Actually, maybe I'll just do it right
here.
So what does this tell me?
It tells me that
T1 hat
of V1
is equal to
T1 hat of V lower bar
plus an integral
from V lower bar to V1
of
X, I'll change
X.
Again, when we start integrating you
have to be careful I
used a new dummy variable here, uh X.
And there's a prime missing, right?
Okay. So this is going to be sort of the
key revenue revenue formula.
Now
why is this so powerful? I think we want
to step back, and at first you might
say, "Okay, we just did a sea of
algebra. What's going on?"
Well, what is this giving me?
It's giving me a formula
for if I'm player one
and my valuation is V1
and we're considering an equilibrium of
this generalized auction, it's giving me
a formula
for the expected payment that I make in
this auction.
Okay?
But let's understand, in general, you
might think that my expected payment
would depend on a lot of things.
You might think it would depend on the
details of the auction and all these
complicated things.
But if we look here, what is it
depending on?
It's depending on two things.
Can someone interpret these these two
terms? These are the only only things
that appear on the right hand side.
So, what is this first term?
>> The base cost of winning the lowest
people.
>> Yeah, so it's just the expected payment
that the lowest possible valuation
person
pays, right? That's the one the one
thing, and I think it you could
interpret it maybe that way. Um
and then what is
Q1 prime? I mean, the prime, let's just
focus on the function Q1 hat. What is
this function Q1 hat?
Can we interpret What is it? What does
it mean?
Uh yeah, maybe I think yeah.
>> It's like the marginal likelihood of
winning for each like infinitesimal
change in your valuation.
>> Uh I think the integral is making you
think about infinitesimal stuff, but
really it's Oh, oh, you're taking the
derivative. Exactly. Sorry, yes. So,
sorry, you jumped ahead. Yes, that's the
derivative of it, exactly. And if we
take away the derivative, it's just
um
my probability of winning, exactly. And
this is the infinitesimal. Sorry, yes,
exactly. I forgot it. Yeah.
Okay. So, what it tells us is that a lot
of the details of the auction doesn't
matter don't matter, right? I mean,
whether we're bidding what we name our
bids, like notice the sets B1 through BN
don't even appear here. All that matters
is the probability that I win the good
in equilibrium and the amount I pay if
I'm the lowest value person.
So, we immediately see
that only a few details of an auction
equilibrium pin down or uniquely
determine the expected payment that
everyone makes.
So, maybe I'll
come over here.
So, WHAT'S THE IMPLICATION?
THAT THE EXPECTED PAYMENT
by
say, bidder one with a valuation is V1
say,
depends
only on
well,
T1 hat V lower bar, which is the
expected payment
of the lowest valuation.
More precisely, the expected payment
that bidder one makes when her valuation
is the lowest possible valuation.
And
we had the derivative here, but if it
depends on the derivative of Q1 hat,
well, it's also depends on Q1 hat, so
it's a bit cleaner to say,
just depends on Q1 hat.
Uh, uh, this function Q1 hat,
which is the
win probability.
And this is entire function, so it's the
win probability of every valuation.
But the point is
in a lot of different equilibria of
different auction formats, these two
values take take very these take very
special values, okay?
So, in many equilibria, in many auctions
that we've looked at so far, what is
So, I'll just say often
Well, INTUITIVELY
WHAT DO YOU THINK T1 hat
of V1 lower bar is often going to be?
Zero, because in most auctions, if you
have the lowest possible valuation for
the item, in most equilibria,
well, you're never going to win.
And if you never going to win, you don't
want to pay anything.
So, often
auction equilibria have this property.
And now, maybe this is a more subtle
one.
What about Q1 hat?
Maybe I'll write Q1 hat of V1.
Well, in a lot of auction equilibria
we've looked at, which bidder wins the
item?
The It's the highest bidder, but another
way of saying it it is it's It's the
bidder who bids the most, that's true,
but it's also the bidder whose valuation
is the highest, right? So, often, when
auctions kind of work well, we might
think that an implicate an outcome of
the auction is that the bidder who
values the item most gets the item.
But if the bidder who values that item
most gets the item,
then what is Q1 hat
Q hat one of V1 going to be?
Well, yeah.
>> Uh,
or as an expectation, um, you know, if
you reduce to be a probability between 0
and 1. Yeah, that's true.
Can we say more about it? Yeah.
In the uniform example, that's exactly
what it would be. But more generally,
maybe let's just write it would be the
probability that everyone else's value
is below V1.
Right? Cuz if it goes to the bidder with
the highest value, what's the
probability that bidder one gets it when
the valuation is V1? It's the
probability that everyone else's value
is below V1. So it's the probability
that the max
of J
not equal to 1 VJ is less than or equal
to V1.
And we actually have notation for this,
right? What is What is our in the in the
symmetric case? What is our notation?
Yeah.
Big G, right? So this is also
Big G
of V1.
Okay.
So we often see that this holds.
Often, you know, it's kind of a in
quotes. But what we see is that, you
know, these are these tend to happen.
And and if that happens, let's plug into
a formula over here.
So
under these conditions,
what does T1 hat of V1 give us?
Well,
what is this first term under those
conditions?
Zero? Okay, so we can forget that.
Q1 hat one of X is what?
Small G of
X. Right, so Q1 hat is big G. And then
when we take the derivative, we get
small G, right? So what we get
is
the integral from V lower bar to V1
of X
G of X DX.
>> of X
Does this look familiar?
This is exactly the formula we had,
right? So, now we understand where it
comes from, right? So, this is not a
special property of first price auctions
or second price auctions. Now, we
understand exactly when this is going to
hold.
This is going to hold in any equilibrium
of any auction that satisfies these two
properties. If whenever my value is the
lowest possible value, I pay nothing.
That's the condition here.
And if the good is always allocated to
the bidder with the highest valuation.
Now, how that happens is going to depend
on the details of the equilibrium, what
the bids are. But, as long as the
auction has that property,
then the expected payments are going to
be the same. They're exactly going to
take this form.
Um so, indeed, it wasn't a coincidence.
It wasn't just something about the first
and second price auction. This is a very
general fact. So, I I think it's good to
kind of understand
I think sometimes when I I I I should
see exactly how it's done in the notes,
revenue equivalents can be stated in two
different ways. Uh so, when people say
only revenue equivalents only holds
under certain conditions, let's
understand this formula always holds, or
always. This This formula holds quite
generally,
but it reduces to this special form
under the additional conditions. So, you
can still apply this formula to an
auction where the good isn't always
allocated to the the person with the
highest valuation, or where the lowest
valuation person pays a positive amount.
This formula still holds, but it reduces
and simplifies under those further
conditions.
Yes.
>> Could you revisit the step of how you
went through kind of taking the
derivative of like our V1 equation
>> Yes.
>> to the revenue formula?
>> Yeah, so
from here to there?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Uh so, you're you're good up to up
to this point?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, we're at this point, and it's
a little spread out, but this is this is
zero over here, right? So, the zero over
here tells me that
uh
V1
times
Q1 hat prime of V1 equals T1 hat prime
of V1.
And now, yeah, I think the way I changed
variables is tricky. Uh I think the best
thing to do would be
wherever you see a V1, let's just put an
X.
So, this tells me X Q1 prime of X equals
T1 prime of X.
Now, I'm going to integrate both sides
from X equals V lower bar
to X equals V1.
>> Okay.
>> So,
when I
integrate the derivative of T1 from V
lower bar to V1, I just get T hat of V1
minus T hat of V lower bar. So, we can
think of that coming to the left-hand
side.
And then, when I integrate this, well, I
exactly get
this.
>> That makes sense.
>> Clear? Okay. Thanks for asking. Any
other questions, please?
So, yeah, it was tricky.
I used V1 here, but then V1 becomes my
dummy variable X, and then I integrate
up to V1. Yeah.
Uh
any other questions?
So, you might say, "Okay, this is kind
of a nice theory, but how can we ever
use this?" Well, it turns out this can
be a convenient way to solve for
equilibria in auctions.
So, let's go over kind of a mini
uh an application of revenue
equivalence.
Maybe I'll call it RET, an application
of the revenue equivalence theorem.
Let's look at the all-pay auction. So,
let's do our our simple case
where we have just two bidders, V1 and
V2,
and they're in 0,1, and they're uniform.
And now, instead of considering the
first-price auction or the second-price
auction, let's consider what's called an
all-pay auction, APA.
So, in an all-pay auction, the
allocation rule is the same as the
first- and second price auction. We
allocate the good to the highest bidder.
So we allocate
to highest bidder.
But everyone has to pay their bids
whether they win or lose.
So I think it should be quite intuitive
here that you don't want to bid very
much in this auction because you know
you have to pay your bid whether or not
you win. So intuitively
uh people will bid less.
But
we might guess
So let's
guess
that there's a
symmetric equilibrium of this auction or
let's look for a symmetric equilibrium
of this auction.
So a symmetric equilibrium
Remember a symmetric equilibrium means
both players are using the same bidding
function, right? So a symmetric
equilibrium means we're looking for a
function
beta
from 0 1
to
maybe 0 to infinity.
So we're looking for a symmetric
equilibrium where both players follow
the bidding strategy beta that says if
my valuation is this, I'm going to bid
beta of my valuation. Okay? So this is
what we're trying to solve for.
Now
go over here.
And we're going to guess a symmetric
equilibrium but with a few more
properties. I think we're going to guess
that there's an equilibrium and also
beta of 0 equals 0
and beta is strictly increasing.
These seem like pretty reasonable
guesses, right? Um so, we think because
the environment's symmetric, maybe
people use symmetric bidding functions.
It seems to make sense that if you if
your value is higher, you should bid
more. That makes sense.
And why do we expect beta of zero to be
zero?
Yeah?
>> You wouldn't want to bid anything
positive if the item isn't worth
anything.
>> Especially because it's an all-pay
auction, right? I mean, that's always
true, but in an all-pay auction, if you
bid something positive, what happens?
You have to pay it. So, you're paying a
positive amount, and even if you get the
good, you don't value it. So, this these
seem like pretty safe guesses, right?
But let's say there is an equilibrium
with this property.
Will our revenue equivalent assumptions
be satisfied?
So, let's check. If there's an
equilibrium with this property, what is
the expected payment
by
someone whose valuation is zero? What's
it going to be?
Just zero, right? If there's an
equilibrium where if my value is zero, I
bid nothing, well, then I'm going to pay
nothing.
It's going to be zero.
And then, if we're both using us the
same strictly increasing bidding
function,
well, which bidder is the good going to
be allocated to?
Yeah.
>> Whoever has the greater value.
>> It's going to go to whichever bidder has
the highest value, because it's going to
go to whichever bidder bids the most,
but we're both using the same increasing
bidding strategy, so who's going to bid
the most? It's going to be the person
who has the higher value. So, it's going
TO BE ALLOCATED
SO, THE TWO CONDITIONS WE NEEDED to get
the revenue formula to simplify are
satisfied.
And that means we immediately know what
the expected payment of each bidder has
to be. So, what does that tell us? Well,
what is Let's just focus on bidder one.
It'll be the same for everyone else.
What is T1 hat of V1 then?
Well, let's go through it, right? It's
the integral
Well, what is V lower bar? It's just
zero.
Zero to V1 of X G of X DX.
What is G of X here?
It's just one, right? Remember, G equals
F if there's two bidders. And if they're
uniform, G is just one.
So,
why G is the density of the
highest valuation among my opponents.
There's only one of them. So, it's just
the density of the uniform distribution,
which is one. So, what do we get?
Same Same thing formula that we always
got before, right?
V1 squared over two.
Notice this is exactly what we got way
at the beginning of class, right? So, in
general, this is always the formula for
the expected payment by a bidder with
valuation V1 in our simple two-bidder
uh uniform distribution case, as long as
our assumptions are satisfied. But now I
claim that we're done. What is the What
must the bidding
uh function be?
So, let's Let's step back and see what
we've done.
We've guessed that this is the bidding
function, beta.
We've said that if this is the bidding
function, beta,
then the expected payment by a bidder
one when the valuation is V1 must
exactly be V1 squared over two.
Yeah?
one half.
It's even easier, right?
It's an all-pay auction.
So, another way of writing the expected
payment
is beta V1.
If it's an all-pay auction, my expected
payment is my bid
cuz I always pay my bid. So, of course,
that's my expected payment.
Right? If I bid two, I always pay two.
If I bid three, I always pay three.
That's my expected payment.
So, what's the answer?
>> V squared over two.
>> That's it, and we're done. So, so we've
now found uh I mean, technically, we
should verify this. We've sort of only
said this is a necessary condition, but
it is true. So, you can check this is
right. Uh
Actually, it's V.
We're done.
So, revenue equivalence can be kind of a
convenient way of actually
solving for an equilibrium because
revenue equivalence gives us a very
simple formula for the expected payment
that each player makes.
This is from revenue equivalence. The
auction format gives us a relationship
between the expected payment and the
bid. In the all-pay auction, it's a very
simple relationship. The expected
payment I make is exactly my bid.
But now,
if we have two different formulas, two
different expressions for T1 out of V1,
they must must both be equal, and now
and now we have this.
Maybe just one more example to see how
we could derive the
uh first-price
auction equilibrium using this.
Basically, we're going to do the reverse
of what we did before at the beginning
of class.
Let's consider a first-price auction
again in our simple example
in our simple
two-bidder
uniform example.
Well,
again, if we look for a symmetric
equilibrium
where if your value is zero, you bid
nothing,
and beta is strictly increasing, then
our two assumptions of revenue
equivalence are going to hold, and
therefore, we know
so revenue equivalence
tells us that t1 hat of v1 equals v1
squared over two.
That's still going to be true as long as
the good goes to the bidder who values
it most, and the bidder with zero value
pays nothing.
But now, from the auction format, what
is
t1 hat of v1?
Yeah?
>> That's the probability of winning times
>> Exactly. So, this should be my bid is
beta of v1
times the probability that I win,
which is v1.
So, now we set these equal, and indeed,
we get
which we already derived before, right?
So, we can sort of go go back and forth.
We can solve for the equilibria. We can
see that revenue equivalence is
satisfied, or we can jump right to
revenue equivalence and use that
together with the rules of the auction
to try to derive what the equilibrium
bidding behavior will be. And this is
useful when we confront new auctions we
haven't looked at before because of how
general revenue equivalence is. Uh I
want to end with maybe one caveat
uh about revenue equivalence though.
And revenue equivalence is often
misinterpreted.
When people interpret revenue
equivalence, they often say it's about
the equivalence between auction formats.
They say something like the first price
auction generates the same revenue as
the second price auction. But if you
want to be really precise, revenue
equivalence is a comparison between an
equilibrium of one auction and an
equilibrium of another auction. So,
caveat,
it's not about so it's not
about the auction
per se, it's about a particular
equilibrium of the auction.
Maybe I'll say BNE
of the auction.
And in fact,
we'll give some examples in a given
auction format, you could have multiple
equilibria that generate different
revenue for the auctioneer if those
conditions aren't satisfied. So, let's
make sure we understand
these conditions
that the bidder with value the lowest
value pays nothing
and the good is allocated to the bidder
with the highest value, these are not
properties simply of the auction format.
They're properties of the equilibrium
together with the auction format.
If everyone used a different bidding
strategy, then this may no longer be
true. Right? So, these assumptions are
not assumptions about the rules of the
auction, they're assumptions about a
particular equilibrium of the auction.
And whenever we apply revenue
equivalence, we're not just comparing
the revenue from two auctions, we're
saying, let's look at equilibrium of one
of this auction and equilibrium two of
auction two and let's compare the
revenue there.
Um
uh so that's kind of a final caveat and
we'll see some uh implications of that
next week. So, I'll stop there. Thank
you.